Ha pasado más de un mes desde el inicio de
la invasión de Ucrania... y las tropas rusas
ya han sufrido su primera gran derrota: han
tenido que abandonar el sitio de Kyiv después
de varias semanas intentando tomar la capital
ucraniana.
A estas alturas ya se puede decir algo y claro
¿Por qué el ejército ruso funciona tan
mal?
¿Cómo es posible que no hayan sido capaces
de tomar ninguna ciudad?
En el vídeo de hoy no vamos a hablar de las
atrocidades cometidas por el ejército ruso.
Vamos a centrarnos únicamente en estrategia
militar y en cuestiones puramente técnicas.
Pensadlo así: esto es el ejército ruso.
Esto es el ejército ucraniano.
En otras palabras: no hay punto de comparación,
Rusia tiene un ejército muy superior a Ucrania.
Además, si algo caracteriza a la Rusia de
Putin es la cultura militarista.
Os lo hemos contado aquí, en VisualPolitik:
el Kremlin ha llegado a construir una CATEDRAL
dedicada a sus fuerzas armadas.
Todos esperábamos que en cuestión de días,
los soldados rusos capturarían Kyiv y los
principales ciudades del país.
Sin embargo, ha pasado más de un mes y Rusia
todavía no ha sido capaz de tomar ninguna
ciudad importante.
Según algunas fuentes, Rusia lleva más de
20.000 bajas (contando muertos y heridos).
El blog ORYX lleva contados más de 2.400
vehículos destruidos o robados.
Para que os hagáis una idea, estas cifras
superan las bajas que sufrió el ejército
americano durante los 20 años que duró la
guerra de Afganistán.
(Por supuesto que los ucranianos también
están sufriendo muchísimas bajas... pero
¡Era de esperar!
Supuestamente, quienes tenían todos los ases
en la manga eran los rusos).
Dicho de otra forma: el ejército ruso ya
contaba con varios fracasos en su historia...
pero todos esperábamos que las reformas de
Putin estaban funcionando.
Y diréis ¿De qué fracasos hablamos?
Desde Georgia hasta Chechenia, todas las guerras
que ha librado Rusia han sido amargas victorias.
Sí, Rusia ganó las guerras de Chechenia
pero a cambio de perder a miles de soldados.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos...
¡Esto es propaganda antirrusa!
Y la respuesta es no.
El propio Vladimir Putin era consciente de
que su ejército no estaba preparado para
una guerra moderna.
Y por eso, en el año 2008, el Kremlin puso
todos sus recursos para poner a su ejército
en el siglo 21.
Para ello, Putin contaba con dos figuras fundamentales:
SERGEI SHOIGU, el ministro de defensa, y VALERY
GERASIMOV, el general jefe del Estado Mayor
Ruso.
Quiero que os quedéis con este nombre: Valery
Gerasimov.
Si sois veteranos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
este nombre os resultará familiar.
Es toda una rockstar del ejército, respetado
por toda la comunidad militar, incluso sus
adversarios de la OTAN.
Muchos dirían que es el padre intelectual
del concepto de la “Nueva Generación de
Guerra”.
De hecho, todos pensábamos que, con Gerasimov
a la cabeza, las fuerzas armadas rusas abandonarían
la herencia soviética y entraban en el siglo
21.
Sin embargo...
estamos viendo que en Rusia todavía persiste
ese viejo adagio que tantas veces se repetía
en época de la Unión Soviética:
“La gente finge que trabaja y el gobierno
finge como que paga” –Viejo proverbio
soviético.
En el vídeo de hoy vamos a evitar centrarnos
en la guerra de Ucrania.
Tampoco vamos a hablar de las armas rusas.
Todo eso lo dejamos para otros dos vídeos
que sacaremos en las próximas semanas.
Porque la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es...
¿Por qué el ejército ruso es semejante
desastre?
¿Qué falla exactamente en las fuerzas armadas
rusas?
¿Cómo es posible que un país tan autoritario,
con una cultura tan militarista, tenga un
ejército tan desorganizado?
Hoy, vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes... vamos a hablar de defensa… de vuestro
ordenador o vuestro móvil.
Internet está lleno de hackers rusos y de
todas partes del mundo.
Y una forma de evitar buena parte de estos
hackeos es usando una VPN ¿Y cuál es la
VPN favorita de VisualPolitik?
¡Exacto!
Surfshark VPN.
Y, creedme, el tema de la ciberseguridad se
lo toman en serio.
Por ejemplo, Surfshark tiene una herramienta
que se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea todos los
popups de propaganda, por donde se cuelan
más bots y cookies que no queremos tener.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, con una misma
cuenta de Surfshark podrás registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras ¿Quieres navegar
con seguridad desde tu SmartTV?
¿Desde tu móvil?
¿Desde tu ordenador?
Puedes hacer todo esto con la misma cuenta
de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos una oferta especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si utilizáis el código POLITIK podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratuitos.
Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
FALTA DE FORMACIÓN
Todos hemos visto imágenes de soldados rusos
capturados por los ucranianos.
La propaganda ucraniana se ha encargado de
difundirlas a bombo y platillo para que todos
veamos cómo llaman a sus madres.
Sin embargo, hay algo muy interesante en estas
imágenes: casi todos los soldados son muy
jóvenes.
En la mayoría, ni siquiera tienen 20 años.
Y esto indica una cosa: son soldados con muy
poca formación.
Así es como se explican que las tropas rusas
estén cayendo como moscas ante el fuego ucraniano.
Y así es como se explican noticias como esta.
Oblast de Kharkiv: dos soldados rusos fueron
a la policía ucraniana a pedir combustible
diesel
Por supuesto que esta noticia es pura propaganda
ucraniana.
Pero es un ejemplo más de los muchos que
hemos visto.
Vamos a decirlo claro: Rusia tiene un problema
muy serio a la hora de entrenar a sus soldados.
La mayoría de sus tropas son reclutas que
están haciendo el servicio militar obligatorio.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se estima que
la cuarta parte de las tropas de élite rusas,
los llamados SPETZNAZ, son reclutas.
Y diréis ¿Por qué?
Para entender esto nos tenemos que remontar
a los tiempos de la Unión Soviética.
Por aquellos años, el servicio militar obligatorio
era de dos años.
Prácticamente todos los hombres soviéticos
tenían que servir en el ejército al llegar
a la mayoría de edad.
Esto tiene una ventaja: la Unión Soviética
contaba con muchísimos soldados.
Pero tiene un problema: 2 años no son un
tiempo suficiente para formarse en la guerra
moderna.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, las grandes
potencias: principalmente Estados Unidos y
la Unión Soviética, entraron en una carrera
militar.
Cuanto más complejas son las armas, más
tiempo de formación necesitan.
Esto explica por qué cada vez hay menos países
que tienen servicio militar obligatorio.
Desde hace varias décadas, casi todos los
ejércitos han hecho un esfuerzo enorme.
Y Rusia no es la excepción.
En el año 2008, el Kremlin redujo el servicio
militar obligatorio.
De 2 años pasaron a 1.
Además, el ejército lanzó una enorme campaña
de reclutamiento: querían contratar a soldados
que estuvieran dispuestos a hacer una carrera
militar.
Soldados profesionales, que pudieran servir
en el ejército durante varios años para
adquirir la experiencia necesaria en la guerra
moderna ¿El problema?
Para contratar soldados necesitas dos cosas:
dinero y gente que quiera alistarse.
Dos cosas que escasean en Rusia.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hoy en día
el ejército ruso tiene alrededor de 850.000
efectivos.
De estos, sólo 405.000 son soldados profesionales.
Y estos soldados profesionales no aguantan
muchos años en el ejército.
Por ejemplo, un sargento de la OTAN puede
servir una media de 15 o 20 años.
En Rusia, es raro encontrar soldados que estén
más de 4.
Por ejemplo, un piloto de caza en la OTAN
tiene que hacer más de 200 horas de vuelo
para poder entrar en combate.
En Rusia, basta con 100 horas.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
¿Y por qué no tienen un problema semejante...
en Israel?
Todos sabemos que Israel también tiene servicio
militar obligatorio.
Tanto los hombres como las mujeres israelíes
tienen que servir en el ejército durante
2 años.
Sin embargo, nadie diría que las tropas israelíes
están mal entrenadas ¿Qué tiene Israel
que no tenga Rusia?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
UN EJÉRCITO...
¡SIN SARGENTOS!
En términos generales, podríamos decir que
hay dos formas de entrar en un ejército:
como soldado o como oficial.
Los oficiales se forman en academias.
En este sentido, Rusia no tiene nada que envidiar
a ningún otro ejército.
Los almirantes, coroneles y generales rusos
tienen una formación equiparable a los de
cualquier otro país.
De nuevo, nadie pone en duda la profesionalidad
de una figura como el General Valery Gerasimov.
El problema es que un ejército necesita algo
más que reclutas y oficiales.
Entre medias hay una figura fundamental: el
suboficial, dicho de otra forma, los sargentos.
Los sargentos son soldados con años de experiencia
que pueden formar a los nuevos reclutas.
Son una figura clave en cualquier ejército.
Y aquí es donde Rusia tiene un problema muy
grave.
Pensadlo así: se calcula que sólo el 1%
de los reclutas se reenganchan en el ejército
tras hacer el servicio militar.
Eso significa que hay muy pocos sargentos
que puedan formar a los nuevos soldados.
Y diréis ¿Por qué nadie se quiere reenganchar
en el ejército ruso?
¿No se supone que tienen una cultura militarista
que glorifica las hazañas de sus fuerzas
armadas?
Recordad que Putin ha llegado a crear milicias
juveniles.
Es decir, en principio, los soldados rusos
tienen más fervor patriótico que los de
ningún otro país.
Y sí, es cierto: el sueño de muchos jóvenes
es alistarse y servir a la madre patria.
Pero, una vez llegan al ejército, se encuentran
con una pesadilla.
Quedaos con esta palabra “DEDOVSHCHINA”.
Atentos.
Un soldado ruso mata a disparos a ocho compañeros
en una base militar en Siberia
El soldado en cuestión disparó a sus compañeros
después de sufrir meses de novatadas y abusos.
La “DEDOVSHCHINA” es la palabra rusa para
referirse a las “novatadas”.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2006,
el suicidio era la causa de muerte del 40%
de los soldados en tiempos de paz.
En el año 2014, 15 reclutas murieron por
novatadas.
Como os podéis imaginar, con una cultura
tan tóxica es lógico pensar que la mayoría
de los soldados rusos no aguanten más de
4 años en el ejército.
De hecho, en el año 2009, Rusia abrió su
primera academia de suboficiales para intentar
suplir esta carencia de sargentos.
Pero esto no es suficiente.
Cada año se gradúan 2000 nuevos suboficiales...
y Rusia necesita muchos más ¿Conclusión?
Ante la falta de sargentos bien formados,
nos encontramos con batallones dirigidos por
reclutas con sólo 1 año de experiencia.
Así que, como tantas veces ocurría en la
Unión Soviética, los generales jóvenes
fingen que dirigen sus batallones y los reclutas
fingen que obedecen.
Y os preguntaréis ¿De verdad Vladimir Putin
tiene la culpa de que el ejército ruso funcione
tan mal?
¿En qué ha consistido esa reforma del ejército
de la que tanto se ha hablado en el Kremlin?
¿Dónde está la influencia del general Valery
Gerasimov?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
TODOS LOS HOMBRES DEL PRESIDENTE
La pregunta que todos os estaréis haciendo
ahora es ¿Cómo es posible que Putin haya
cometido semejante error de cálculo?
Todo apunta a que Rusia esperaba una guerra
relámpago.
Pensaban que el ejército ucraniano no iba
a resistir y que la sociedad recibiría a
los libertadores rusos con los brazos abiertos.
Evidentemente no ha sido así.
La pregunta es ¿No había ningún servicio
de inteligencia asesorando a Vladimir Putin?
Pensad que no hablamos de un pequeño error
de cálculo sino de una invasión en toda
regla donde Rusia lleva acumulando más de
20.000 bajas ¿De verdad no hay nadie en el
ejército ruso que haya informado a Putin?
Pues por extraño que parezca, todo apunta
a que no.
De hecho, no deja de ser llamativa la ausencia
de Valery Gerasimov en las últimas semanas.
Se trata de la rockstar del ejército ruso:
algo así como la versión rusa de lo que
fue el General Petraeus en Estados Unidos.
¿De verdad es realista pensar que Putin está
microgestionando la guerra de Ucrania?
En realidad, no sería la primera vez en la
que un político microgestiona una guerra.
Lo vimos durante la Guerra de Vietnam.
En ese caso, el por entonces presidente de
Estados Unidos, Lindon B. Johnson, llegó
a gestionar los detalles más minuciosos desde
su Despacho Oval.
El resultado fue la vergüenza más absoluta
para el ejército estadounidense.
Además, pensadlo así: durante años, Rusia
ha evolucionado en una dictadura personalista...
y eso también afecta al ejército.
Pensadlo así: durante la época soviética,
Rusia era una dictadura sin paliativos.
Ahora bien, el principal órgano de decisión
era el POLITBURÓ: el comité central del
Partido Comunista.
Podía tener hasta 35 miembros que discutían
todas las decisiones.
Hoy en día, el politburó soviético ya no
existe y ahora tenemos esto.
Puede parecer una caricatura, pero todo apunta
a lo mismo: una dictadura personalista.
Un sistema político donde un hombre tiene
el poder de tomar todas las decisiones sin
ningún contrapeso.
Y sí, esto se nota en el ejército.
Por ejemplo: en casi todos los países, las
fuerzas armadas están dirigidas por el Alto
Estado Mayor, que a su vez depende del Ministerio
de Defensa.
Sin embargo, Rusia cuenta con un ejército
especial.
Una especie de Guardia Pretoriana de Putin.
Hablamos de la Guardia Nacional, conocida
por el nombre de ROSGVARDIA.
Este cuerpo fue creado por el propio Putin
en el año 2016.
Tiene más de 340.000 efectivos y está dirigida,
directamente, por Vladimir Putin.
Dicho de otra forma, más de la tercera parte
de todos esos 850.000 soldados rusos está
fuera del ejército regular.
Es decir, no dependen del General Gerasimov
ni de Sergei Shoigu.
Reciben órdenes directas del Presidente.
Puede que os sorprenda pero esto es una constante
en casi todos los regímenes autoritarios.
Muchos pensaríais que el ejército funciona
mejor en una dictadura militarista que en
una democracia.
Sin embargo, los líderes autoritarios rara
vez confían plenamente en su ejército.
Eso explica que Putin haya creado su propia
guardia pretoriana.
En principio, esta “guardia nacional”
no es un cuerpo pensado para combatir en guerra.
Podríamos decir que son una especie de policía
militarizada.
Su objetivo es el control territorial de la
propia Rusia: en decir luchar contra grupos
insurgentes, grupos terroristas o reprimir
protestas.
Ahora bien ¿Recordáis que, oficialmente,
Rusia no está en guerra?
Según el Kremlin, la invasión de Ucrania
es una “misión especial” para “desnazificar”
un territorio lleno de insurgentes antirusos
¿Conclusión?
Es muy probable que Putin esté intentando
enviar a la Guardia Nacional.
Y eso explica noticias como esta:
Doce miembros de la Rosgvardia fueron despedidos
por su renuncia a unirse a la invasión
Pensadlo bien: esta guardia nacional no está
entrenada para una guerra como tal.
Enviarles al frente es una sentencia de muerte
para muchos.
Pero recordad que hablamos de todo un sistema
político centrado en la figura de Putin ¿Quién
se atrevería a discutirle en estos momentos?
Pensadlo así: prácticamente todas las figuras
claves del ejército y de la industria militar
están puestas a dedo por el Presidente.
Su partido, Rusia Unida, ocupa casi todos
los puestos del parlamento (de 450 escaños
que tiene la duma rusa, 325 pertenecen al
partido de Putin).
En otras palabras: no existen contrapesos
al poder del Kremlin.
Eso significa que nadie puede cuestionar los
errores de cálculo del propio Putin...
incluida la invasión de Ucrania.
A estas alturas, nadie puede negar que Putin
calculó mal sus fuerzas.
Esperaba que sus tropas conquistarían Kyiv
en unos pocos días y que los ucranianos les
recibirían con los brazos abiertos.
En una democracia, los servicio de inteligencia
habrían podido informar al presidente con
libertad.
Llevarle la contraria y explicarle la realidad
en el campo.
Los propios generales podrían preparar una
estrategia realista basada en un conocimiento
más exhaustivo de su músculo militar.
Pero, en este caso, lo que estamos viendo
es a un ex directivo de la KGB, sin formación
militar, tomando decisiones sin que nadie
le conteste.
Y eso explica fracasos como este.
Los oficiales ucranianos dicen que las tropas
Rusas abandonan las áreas cercanas a Kyiv
De nuevo, Putin está fingiendo que la invasión
de Ucrania no es una guerra... y espera que
su guardia nacional y su ejército finjan
que lucha en una operación especial.
La pregunta ahora es ¿De verdad veremos cómo
se reorganiza el ejército ruso y vuelve a
atacar Kyiv?
¿Hasta qué punto Rusia puede ganar esta
guerra sin tener que echar mano de sus armas
nucleares?
Y otra pregunta de otro tema… si las camisas
hawaiianas son la seña de identidad de VisualPolitik,
los chalecos son la seña de identidad de
Megaprojekts…
¿CUÁL será el “uniforme” que nos pondremos
en VisualEconomik?
Sí, habéis oído bien: estamos a punto de
lanzar un canal hermano: VisualEconomik donde,
como si propio nombre indica, hablaremos de
todo lo que siempre habéis querido saber
sobre economía y nunca os habéis atrevido
a preguntar.
Por ejemplo…
¿Quién es de verdad George Soros?
¿Por qué es tan rico?
¿Cuáles son sus planes para Europa?
De eso tratará nuestro primer vídeo en VisualEconomik,
terminado en K de VisualPolitik.
Y diréis ¿Cuándo publicaremos ese vídeo?
Pues apuntad la fecha: DOMINGO 10 de ABRIL
a las 8 de la tarde hora española.
No esperéis más, suscribíos al canal y
apuntaros la fecha.
Os esperamos en esta nueva aventura…
os esperamos en VisualEconomik!
Y, por supuesto, ya podéis dejarnos en los
comentarios ¿Cómo creéis que iremos vestidos?
Y después de este anuncio, si este vídeo
os ha gustado, ya sabéis, dadle a LIKE y
nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.